ja immer sein häkeln und opa soll bingo
spielen und beide sollen bloß keinen sex
haben denn das ist ja eklig finden viele
nicht aber diese frau nadine kopf sie
ist prostituierte und sie geht in
pflege- und altenheime ja um dort mit
den menschen zu schlafen oder einfach um
ihn körperliche nähe zu geben der den
kopf ist uns jetzt auch zugeschaltet
hallo und guten tag frau kopf schön dass
sie bei uns sind hallo ich grüße
herzlich frau kopp ehrlich gesagt ich
bin hin und hergerissen ob ich sie ganz
toll finde oder ob ich das nicht doch
auch selbst ein bisschen eklig finden
was sie machen wie geht es ihnen selbst
empfinden sie manchmal ekel
na ja also ich was heißt das heißt wir
werden alle alt und wir haben einfach
einfach das bedürfnis und ich finde es
eigentlich eher traurig dass jeder
einfach so denkt dass man einfach sagt
ja das ist einfach total eklig da muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen dürfen wir nicht
alt werden dafür ja keine bedürfnisse
haben ist dürfen wir keine
zärtlichkeiten mehr verspüren also
dürfen wir verstehen einfach nicht was
ist daran eklig ja es ist ja nicht so
dass ich jetzt unbedingt mit jedem
schlafen zu es geht um ganz ganz viel
mehr um einfach fertigkeiten nie
sozialen kontakt und viele da reicht
einfach nicht nur einfach das kuscheln
sondern wir möchten einfach wieder an
anderen menschen einfach spüren
die möchten vielleicht einfach wieder an
ihre frau denken oder ihre freundin weil
vielleicht auch von von diagnostik her
sie vielleicht einfach auch im jahre
zurückversetzt sind was ist denn besser
dass die menschen vielleicht ständig
irgendwie sexuelle übergriffe machen
oder ss mörder oder vielleicht auch sich
irgendwelche sachen wie globe ersten
sonst irgendwas irgendwo japan schieben
benutzen fragen sie mal im krankenhaus
nach notfall chirurgie was sie alles
schon eingesammelt haben oder ist es
besser wenn man die einfach unterstützt
eine pflegekraft wird wohl nicht
irgendwie ein vibrator oder sonst
irgendwas den menschen irgendwie
hantieren ja frau korb wie läuft das
denn genau ab was sind die wünsche der
senioren wie spielt sich das ab wenn sie
zum beispiel in ein altersheim kommen
wird da getuschelt heißt es danach frau
kopp ist
da die geht jetzt immer zwei zu herrn
huber wie läuft das ab wie fühlen sie
sich dabei und was wünschen sie sich die
senioren
naja also überwiegend es einfach die
zärtlichkeit der einfach der dass das
spüren einer anderen körpernähe oder
einfach auch nur dass die darüber
sprechen über ihre sexualität die buchen
mich ganz normal wie jeder andere mensch
auch ob frau mann eingeschränkt über die
digitalen medien oder in der zeitung
haben sie meine nummer gesehen rufen
mich an wir haben vor gespräch und dann
ist es einfach so wo ich dann selber
auch entscheide ja klappt das oder
klappt das nicht man stellt sie vor
persönlich ja und dann entscheidet man
ob man einfach die wünsche erfüllen kann
oder einfach nicht aber meistens ist es
wirklich ist es ist nicht der
eigentliche akt an sich was viele halt
einfach nicht verstehen sondern einfach
sozusagen die unterstützung ja ein
querschnittsgelähmter wie soll denn
bitte schön sex haben er kann es
vielleicht und haben ihre erektion und
alles aber ist es nicht möglich den
eigentlichen akt vielleicht zu
verrichten und da brauchte einfach
unterstützung ja oder auch
uneingeschränkte geistiger mensch ja ich
verstehe sind wird das ganz
beeindruckend ist ganz beeindruckend wie
sie das schildern frau kopp sie geben so
viel von sich persönlich was bekommen
sie zurück das ist doch auch das thema
in der pflege man gibt so viel von sich
wird vielleicht auch ein stück
ausgezehrt was bekommen sie persönlich
zurück von diesen menschen bekomme ich
einfach dankbarkeit zurück
ich bekomme dankbarkeit zurück ich
bekomme einfach auch eine wertschätzung
zurück dass ich mich überhaupt da mit
diesem thema annehmen weil genau jeder
einfach genau wie jetzt auch mit dem
schutz der einfach dagegen spricht und
die menschen sagen einfach auch wenn ich
alt bin oder eingeschränkt genutzt uns
irgendwie gleichen ich bin einfach
mensch und ich habe einfach bedürfnisse
und ich möchte einfach ein stück liebe
haben und das geben die mehr auf eine
andere art und weise zurück
wertschätzung achtung sie nicht
angesprochen frau corp wertschätzung und
achtung in den sozialen medien bekommen
sie jetzt teilweise das gegenteil sie
haben von einem schützen gesprochen sie
haben uns auch einige der hass
kommentare mitgebrachte wollen wir
einmal reinschauen was sie derzeit für
nachrichten bekommen
mama mama wenn ich mal groß
ich bin will ich auch das machen dreck
in meinen augen wenn sie solche
nachrichten bekommen für die arbeit die
sie machen einsamen menschen helfen was
geht dann in ihnen vor was möchten sie
diesen menschen sagen die insel schicken
ich finde es einfach traurig wie gesagt
werden die nicht älter na also man hat
einfach das bedürfnis und das andere ist
einfach selbst als pflegekraft ich habe
mit fäkalien und so weiter zu tun
ich umarme die menschen auch teilweise
und ist und einfach dankbar darüber dass
würde überhaupt nicht das ist auch eine
eine intimität was es denn was ist dann
besser mit jemandem sozusagen zu
kuscheln auch mal oder sozusagen eine
andere dinge zu verrichten und deswegen
man sollte sich einfach mal gedanken
machen dass man vielleicht vor jedem
alter und vor jedem menschen einfach ein
bisschen achtung hat und das ist einfach
wie jetzt auch im jungen alter das man
bedürfnisse hat das haben sie
beeindruckend geschildert herzlichen
dank für ihre erzählung danke dass es
sie gibt prokop wir sind bild und wie
ihr liefert dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren